you are part of the Harvard black hole
initiative which has theoretical
physicists experimentalists and even
philosophers so let me ask the big
question what is a black hole from a
theoretical from an experimental uh
maybe even from a philosophical
perspective so a black hole is defined
theoretically
as a region of space-time
from which light can never Escape
therefore it's black
now that's just the starting point many
weird things uh follow from that basic
definition but that is
that is the basic definition what is
light
they can't escape from a black hole well
light is uh you know the stuff that
comes out of the Sun that stuff that
goes into your eyes
um light is one of the the stuff that
disappears when the lights go off this
is stuff that appears when the lights
come on
um of course I could give you a Beth a
medical definition but
um or physical mathematical definition
but I think it's something that we uh
will understand very intuitively
what is light black holes on the other
hand we don't understand intuitively
they're very weird
and
one of the questions is about black
holes which I think you were alluding to
is you know why doesn't light get out or
how is it that there can be a region of
space-time
from which light can't escape
it definitely happens we've seen those
regions we have spectacular pictures
especially in the last several years of
those regions
um they're there
in fact they're up in the sky thousands
or millions of them
we don't yet know how many
um but the proper explanation
of why light doesn't escape from
uh
a black hole is still a matter of some
debate
um
and
one explanation
which perhaps Einstein might have given
is that light carries energy
you know it carries energy because
you know we have uh photo cells and we
can take Delight from the Sun and
collect it turn it into electricity so
there's energy in light
and anything that carries energy is
subject to a gravitational pull
gravity will pull at anything with
energy
now it turns out that the gravital
gravitational pull
exerted by an object
uh is proportional to its mass
and so if you get enough Mass
in
a small enough region
um
you you can prevent light from escaping
and let me flesh that out a little more
um if you're
on the Earth
and you're on a rocket ship leaving this
the surface of the Earth and if we
ignore the friction from the air
um if your rocket accelerates up to 11
kilometers per second
that's escape velocity
and it can if there were no friction it
could just continue forever to the next
galaxy
on the moon which has less Mass it's
only seven kilometers per second
so but going in the other direction if
you have
enough mass in one place the escape
Velocity
can become the speed of light
if you shine light straight up away from
the earth it doesn't have too much
trouble it's going way above the escape
Velocity
and
but if you have enough Mass there even
light can't escape the escape Velocity
and according to
Einstein's theory of relativity there is
an absolute speed limit in the universe
the speed of light
and nothing
makes any sense nothing could be
self-consistent if there are objects
that could exceed light speed
and so uh in these very very massive
regions of space-time even light cannot
escape and the interesting thing is
Einstein himself didn't think that these
uh objects we call the black holes could
exist but let me actually Linger on this
yeah that's incredibly interesting
there's a lot of interesting things here
first of the speed limit
how Wild is it to you if you put
yourself in the mind in the time of
Einstein before him to come up with a
speed limit of that there is a speed
limit that and that speed limit is the
speed of light how difficult of an idea
is that is it you know you said from a
mathematic
mathematical physics perspective
everything just kind of falls into place
but he wasn't
perhaps maybe initially had the luxury
to think mathematically he had to come
up with it intuitively yes so like what
how common intuitive is this notion to
you well is it still crazy what no no so
it's a very funny thing in physics the
best discoveries
seem completely obvious in retrospect
yeah
even my own discoveries which of course
are far lesser than Einsteins but many
of my papers many of my collaborators
get all confused we'll try to understand
something we said we've got to solve
this problem we'll get all confused
finally we'll solve it we'll get it all
together
and um
then we'll all of a sudden everything
will fall into place we'll explain it
and then we'll look back at our
discussions for the precedings of months
and literally be unable to reconstruct
how confused we were yeah and how we
could ever have thought of it any other
way
so not only can I not fathom
how confused
Einstein was
before he when you know when he started
thinking about the issues I can't even
reconstruct my own confusion from from
two weeks ago I I you know so the really
beautiful ideas that physics have this
very hard to get yourself back into the
mindset of course Einstein was confused
about many many things
um
it doesn't matter if you're a physicist
it's not how many things you got wrong
it's not the ratio of how many you got
wrong coming you got right it's the
number that you got right
so Einstein didn't believe black holes
existed even though he predicted them
and I went and I read that paper which
he wrote you know Einstein wrote down
his field equations and in 1915 and
short Shield solved them and discovered
the black hole solution uh three or four
months later in very early 1916.
and um 25 years later Einstein wrote a
paper so with 25 years to think about
what this solution means yeah wrote a
paper in which he said that black holes
didn't exist
and I I'm like whoa you know if one of
my students in my general relativity
course wrote this
you know I wouldn't pass them I get I
get to see mine oh you wouldn't pass
them okay all right get to see by this
okay same thing with gravity waves he
didn't believe oh he didn't believe in
gravitational waves either he went back
and forth but he wrote a paper and I
think 34 saying that gravity waves
didn't exist because it people were very
confused about what a coordinate
transformation is and in fact this
confusion about what a coordinate
transformation
is has persisted
and we actually think
we were on the
edge of solving it
100 years later
well what a hundred years later what is
coordinate transformation as it was a
hundred years ago to today let's imagine
I want to draw a map with pictures of
all the states and the mountains and
then I want to draw the weather forecast
what the temperatures are going to be
all over the country
and I do that using one set of weather
stations
and I number the weather stations
and you have some other set of
weather stations
and you
do the same thing so the coordinates are
the locations of the weather stations
yeah they're how we describe where the
things are
at the end of the day
we should draw the same
map
that is coordinate invariance
and if we're telling somebody uh we're
going to tell somebody at a real
physical operation we want you to stay
as dry as possible on your drive from
here to California
um we should give them exactly the same
route
no matter which weather stations we use
or how we you know it's a very trivial
it's it's the labeling of points is an
artifact and not in the real physics
sure
so it turns out that that's
almost true
but but not quite there's some
subtleties to it
the statement that you should always
have the same give this the same kind of
trajectory same kind of uh instructions
no matter the weather station yeah yeah
there's some very delicate subtleties to
that which
began to be noticed in the in the 50s
it's mostly true but when you have a
space time with edges
it gets very tricky how you label the
edges and space time in terms of spacer
in terms of time in terms of everything
just based on either one okay space or
time that gets very tricky and Einstein
uh didn't
didn't have it right and in fact he had
an earlier version of general relativity
in 1914 which he was very excited about
um which was
wrong
um gave it wasn't fully coordinate and
variant it was only partially
coordinated variant it was wrong
it gave the wrong answer for bending
light to the Sun
by a factor of two
there was an expedition
sent out to measure it during World War
One
they were captured
before they could measure it and that
came that came Einstein four more years
to clean it to clean his act act up by
which time he had gotten it right
so it's a very it's a very tricky
business but once it's all laid out it
saves uh
it's it's it's clear then what do you
think Einstein
didn't uh believe his own equations and
didn't think that black holes are real
well why was that such a difficult idea
for him well something very interesting
happens in
short Shield solution of the Einstein
equation
I think his reasoning was ultimately
wrong but let me
explain to you uh
what it was
um
at the center of the black hole behind
the horizon
in a region that nobody can
see and live to tell about it
as a center of the black hole there's a
singularity and if you pass the Horizon
you go into the singularity you get
crushed and that's the end of everything
now the word singularity
means that
um
it just means that Einstein's equations
break down
they become infinite you write them down
you put them on the computer when the
computer hits that Singularity it
crashes
everything becomes infinite there's two
so the questions are just no good there
now
that's actually
not a bad thing it's a really good thing
and let me explain why
um
so
it's an odd thing
that Maxwell's Theory
and Newton's Theory
never
exhibit this phenomena you write them
down you can solve them exactly they're
really Newton's theory of gravity
they're really very simple theories you
can solve them well you can't solve the
three body problem but
um
you can certainly solve a lot of things
about them
uh nevertheless
there was never any reason
even though Maxwell and Newton perhaps
fell for this trap there were never any
reason to think that these equations
were exact
um and
every there's no equation
well
there's some equations that we've
written down that we still think are
exact
some people still think are exact my
view is that there's no exact equation
everything is an approximation
everything is an approximation are you
trying to get as close as possible yeah
so you think are you saying objective
truth doesn't exist in this world
the internet is going to be very much we
could discuss that but that's a
different okay that's a different thing
um we wouldn't say Newton's theory was
wrong
it had very very small Corrections
incredibly small Corrections it's
actually a puzzle why they're so small
so if you watch the procession of
Mercury's perihelia this was the first
indication
of something going wrong it corrected
Newton's Theory mercury has an
elliptical orbit
the long part of it moves around
as other planets come by and perturb it
and so on and so this was measured by
leveria in 1859 and he compared
Theory and experiment and he found out
that the perihelion process moves around
the Sun
once every
233 centuries instead of every 231
centuries
okay now this is the wonderful thing
about science
why was this guy
I read you to give any idea how much
work this is you know
but of course he made one of the
greatest discoveries of the history of
science without you know even knowing
what it what good it was going to be
foreign
so that's how small that that was the
first sign that there was something
wrong with Newton yeah
nah so the corrections to Newton's law
are very very small but they're
definitely there
the corrections to electromagnetism
they're mostly the ones that we see are
mostly coming from Quantum effects
and so so the corrections there for uh
Maxwell's equations is when you get
super tiny and then the corrections for
the
um for Newton's uh laws gravity is when
you get super big
that that that's when you require
Corrections that's true but I would
phrase it as saying when it's super
accurate you know if you look at the
Bohr Adam
Maxwell electromagnetism is not a very
good approximation to the force between
the proton
and the electron the quantum mechanics
if you if you if you didn't have quantum
mechanics the electron would would
spiral into the proton and the atom
would collapse it's Quantum you know so
that's a huge correction there sure
so every Theory gets corrected as we
learn more
you're just no reason to suppose that it
should be otherwise how is this really
to the singularity why does it go there
so when you hit the singularity
you know that you need some
Improvement
to Einstein's theory of gravity
and that Improvement we understand what
kind of things that Improvement should
involve it should involve quantum
mechanics Quantum effects become
important there it's a small thing
and um
we don't understand exactly what the
theory is but we know there's no reason
to think you know Einstein's theory was
invented to describe
weekly curves things the solar system
and so on it it's incredibly robust that
we now see that it works very well uh
near the horizons of around black holes
and so on so so it's a good thing
that the theory drives itself
that it predicts its own demise
Newton's gravity had its demise
there were regimes in which it wasn't
valid
Maxwell's electromagnetism had its
demise there was uh
regimes in which Quantum effects greatly
modified
the equations
but
general relativity all on its own
found draw a system which originally was
fine
would perversely wander off into a
configuration in which Einstein's
equations no longer applied so to you
the edges of the theory are wonderful
the failures the edges are wonderful
because that keeps that keeps us in
business so that one of the things you
said I think in your Ted Talk that uh
the the fact that quantum mechanics and
uh and relativity
don't describe everything and then they
Clash is wonderful right I forget the
adjective you used but it was something
like this so why is that uh why is that
interesting to you in that same way that
there's contradictions that create
Discovery there's no question in my mind
of course many people would disagree
with me that now is the most
wonderful time to be a physicist so so
people people look back at at
um it's a classical thing to say
among physicists uh I wish it were 1920.
right quantum mechanics had been just
understood
uh there was the periodic table
there was but in fact that was such a
rich thing
that
uh
well so that what a lot of exciting
stuff happened around 1920. it took it
took the whole it took a whole century
to sort out the new insights that we got
especially adding some experimental
stuff into the bit into the bunch
actually making observations and adding
all the experimental things computers
also help with visualizations and all
that kind of stuff yeah yeah yeah it was
a whole sort of Wonderful
Century I mean the seed of
general relativity was the
incompatibility of Maxwell's Theory
of the electromagnetic field
with Newton's laws of gravity they were
incompatible because
if you look at Maxwell's Theory
there's a contradiction if anything goes
faster than the speed of light
but Newton's theory of gravity
the uh
gravitational field the gravitational
force is instantaneously transmitted
across the entire universe
so you could you know if you had a
a a friend on you know in another galaxy
with a very sensitive
measuring device that could measure the
gravitational field that could just take
this cup of coffee and move it up and
down and Morse code and they could get
the message instantaneously over another
galaxy that leads to all kinds of
contradictions it's not it's not
self-consistent
it was exactly in resolving those
contradictions that Einstein came up
with the general theory of of
relativity and it's fascinating how this
contradiction which seems like maybe
it's kind of technical thing
led to a whole new vision of the of the
universe
now let's not get fooled because
lots of contradictions are technical
things we haven't set up the
we run into other kinds of
contradictions that are Technical and
they they don't seem to they we just we
understood something wrong we made a
mistake we set up equations in the wrong
way we didn't translate the formalisms
as opposed to revealing some deep
mystery that's yet to be uncovered yeah
yeah and so we never we're never very
sure which are which are the really
important ones
but to you the difference between
quantum mechanics and general relativity
seem the the tension the contradiction
there seems to hint at some deeper
deeper thing that's going to be
discovered in the century yes because
that one has been understood since the
50s poly was the
uh first person to notice it and Hawking
in the early 70s gave it a really much
more visceral form
um and people have been
hurling themselves at it trying to
reduce it to some technicality but
nobody has succeeded and the efforts to
understand it have led to
uh all kinds of interesting relations
between Quantum systems and and
applications to other fields and and so
on